[Music]
hey everyone this is stephanie wong and
we are
back today with networking specialist
ryan prisball
you might recognize him from our popular
series networking 101
102 3 4 and 5 where he covered google
cloud's networking fundamentals with me
and last time he discussed how
enterprise networking in the cloud is
changing from
traditional to service oriented
networking a mentality shift for
companies and
cloud providers alike and today we're
covering how you can approach these
changes
and how google cloud specifically is
addressing it and evolving with it
so before i start i just want to mention
please please comment below with
questions
anything that we didn't get to last time
we are going to take a look at all of
them
so definitely chat us and make sure that
we can get to all of your questions
and for ryan to kick it right off
last time we talked about customers
moving newer applications to the cloud
and adopting service oriented networking
functionalities
so what do we provide as a stepping
stone
to enable enterprises who do use this
traditional networking model
yeah so i think google is continuing to
evolve
our networking layer constructs and i
think all the cloud providers are doing
this right
um and there's a lot of interesting
internal conversations that i have with
you know engineers and product managers
i think everybody wants to work on
the newest latest greatest things right
and i'm constantly having to remind
people that
you know there's a lot of fundamental
stuff that we still need to work on as
well and maybe it's not the bright shiny
object
sexy thing to work on but it's it's very
critical for an enterprise right
the more products and tools i can offer
to
sort of replicate your data center
environment which i sort of touched on
last time
right the more of those features i have
the more
you can kind of pick and choose how you
want to migrate right and what stepping
stones you want to integrate so you
could have sort of like
okay i'm going to move like this and
it's going to be literally a mirror
image of my data center right and that
assumes we had every networking product
working every way you wanted it
you know you could do that and then say
you know after i migrate to ten thousand
applications
i'm gonna make this change and that's
gonna be my first stepping stone right
the reality is you know none of the
cloud providers are completely there yet
right like we're having to literally
re-engineer
you know 50 years of telecom into this
cloud environment right into the sdn
and you know we're building all sorts of
products and features that
maybe have been very traditional for
many many years but
the bottom line is because we're
building all these constructs not
necessary from scratch but
we have to build all those features in
right so like as an example if you do a
lot of routing with
say communities and local pref and
things like that
at a routing layer you know that's not
something you could just bring into
google cloud today right and use like a
cloud router to do that so that's like a
point like a function that isn't there
that we need to continue to evolve and
again
all cloud providers are sort of in this
boat so
in terms of the stepping stones like i
want to be able to continue to push
google and continue
to build all of those tools that give
the customer those stepping stones to
say i want to make these little
incremental changes
the worst thing the worst thing i have
to do is like get with a customer and
say
you can't do it it has to be done this
way because as i mentioned before
depending on what
that particular way is that could be a
very big
you know chunk to bite off and be very
difficult for the customer to
adopt okay so i'm always cognizant of
that and that's why
you know again coming with a very
traditional networking background i'm
always pushing us to keep
developing those small stepping stones
that customers can place
to help them make that change now a good
example
of like let's say you or a traditional
you know network
infrastructure sort of setup and you
wanted to say start introducing some of
these
um service sort of constructs so i
talked about psc private service connect
before
you could say i want to use psc to
frontend a particular google api
and i just want to try it out that way
or maybe you're using a cloud service
maybe you're using something like
snowflake or
something else that's really designed
and kind of grew up in the cloud
and that would be a great place to like
introduce some of these
service sort of layer constructs into
the model where you're not trying to
like also change everything but you're
just saying
i want to front maybe the google apis
with a psc endpoint
you know tons of customers use google
apis every day to do all sorts of things
that would be a great sort of like
stepping stone
and then you get to sort of understand
like how does psc work
just talking about for the people who do
want visibility and control over
building something like a nat gateway
and handling routing what's been the
response from providers like google
cloud
yeah so this kind of goes back to like
there's still things that we are
building so
like when you take psc and it's it's
being a managed service where we're
handling that in and we're handling
routing under the covers right let's
take
that case right like we understand that
there's still product development work
that we have to do on that functionality
right and we are constantly
evolving so this is kind of what i'm
referring to
when when we talk about you know
customers aren't always
you know comfortable with losing that
visibility but it's incumbent on your
cloud provider to understand where
you're coming from and why you're coming
from there and continue to
evolve their networking technology now
that being said natting is nothing new
right it is a very old technology that's
been around for a long time
it's just certain levels of
functionality we have yet to develop
right
so i think this is a key point we talked
a little bit about like
i think most people agree like the
service networking model is the way
forward right if you look
20 years from now right everybody's
going to be using sort of that paradigm
i think
okay but and it's easy to continue to
say that's the cutting-edge stuff let's
go and develop that stuff right
versus something that say like matting
that is an old
technology one approach is well let the
customers manage it they can put their
own nat gateways in there they can do
things themselves and
and there are ways to do this stuff but
you know we want to continue to enable
customers with easy to use easy to
consume services right so
like i said we're doing more work on
that front to expand our capabilities
so a customer who's like maybe not
entirely comfortable using pse
because they lose some visibility things
you know we're giving them
more and more of that network layer
functionality so that they can build
again kind of like what they have in the
data center to replicate it as much as
possible
to give them that comfort factor of
getting into cloud and then once they're
in cloud
start to look at some of these other
technologies right and i do know that we
have
some visibility and intelligence options
for example we just came out
in the last couple years network
intelligence center which gives you
visibility
for things like running connectivity
tests between endpoints
or monitoring your performance through
dashboard or looking at your topology
from a visual standpoint and so this
seems like it's more in the realm of a
service oriented model but do you
consider this
an overlapping area where we can start
to br
build bridges um and allow traditional
networking architects and engineers
understand
how to get visibility in a service
oriented environment yeah
it's it's really interesting because you
know i've been in the space for 20 years
and i've touched i don't have any
thousands of networks but they're
they're all built differently right
nobody builds you know two networks are
you know kind of like a fingerprint
they're all slightly different right and
it's our job to sort of understand that
but one fundamental is being able to
troubleshoot them when they break
okay and as i mentioned earlier when you
move into the cloud and you move into
sort of our sdn and how things have been
built under the hood right that isn't
always
you know easily understandable by
customers right
so tools like network intelligence
center
are designed to help sort of bridge that
gap okay
you may have a very traditional way of
troubleshooting your network and saying
like okay
i can see all these paths but things
like a trace route for example which is
a
very common troubleshooting tool right
it doesn't always give you the
information that maybe it would in your
data center you can see like okay i'm
hopping here i'm hopping here i'm
hopping to a firewall i'm going through
the fire while i'm hopping to another
router right like
you don't typically get that kind of
information so
just as an example when you build a vm
we program route tables onto that vm we
program firewall rules on that vm
so if traffic isn't getting to that vm
is it
because it can't route to that vm is it
because there's a firewall rule that's
blocking the traffic right so
you know again from a traditional
networking standpoint of view you might
use traceroute and say oh i see it went
from
the original server it went to the
router from the router it went to the
firewall and then i see it stop
right oh well it's the firewall that's
blocking it but what do you do when the
firewall the routes all the stuff live
on the vm
what is it that's actually causing the
packet not to get there
so that's where things like network
intelligence center they help bridge
that gap
right and and i think it's key to note
that there are tools
and modes of thinking that still are
applicable in this case you can always
run a trace route
even if your applications live in the
cloud and we also have tools and logging
and monitoring like cloud trace
so i think it's it's sort of just
understanding where to map
certain concepts and how they how they
translate into the cloud
um but do you find most companies in
general who operate
in a network-centric model more or less
eager to adopt this service-oriented
model
of networking um eager to adopt like i
said i think
depending on who you talk to it might be
a yes it might be a no
again having a traditional network
engineering background it's a little bit
scary when you start talking about
you know we're gonna put a whole bunch
of sidecar envoy proxies in there and
we're gonna start talking about service
meshes and service discovery and we're
going to start abstracting the network
where we're really just
you know this service needs to connect
to another service we'll just push it to
the envoy proxy and let the envoy proxy
figure out how to
to handle this right so again you're
kind of abstracting the network away as
a
as a networking guy it's kind of like
well are you obstructing my job away
like this
this is what i've been dealing with for
20 years right and the answer is
ultimately no like the network still
exists
but it's a fundamental like shift like a
mental shift that you're having to make
to sort of adapt with the time so
i think most people see like that is the
path forward
but on one level it seems kind of
simple you talk about like oh we're
gonna talk about service service
networking we're talking about service
meshes and service discoveries and
you know even if you decide to break a
monolithic app down
into you know microservice and things
like that
it's easy to whiteboard this stuff out
sometimes right implementing it is a
total another ball game
if you want to see a really good video
on this if you go to the envoy proxy
website
matt klein over at lyft did sort of a
history of lyft and sort of how they
integrated a lot of these level
constructs
into lift's environment um it is a great
sort of trying to get your hand or heads
or getting your head around
you know a monolithic app you know being
broken into these you know smaller
services and really what
service networking really looks like and
all the complexities around it it's
probably an hour long watch but i
thought matt did a really good job of
describing like
hey this this seems easy on one hand but
in reality
it is it is a lot more complex so to
your point
this is why you know these very large
traditional enterprises
i think they see that path forward but
it's super scary when you start watching
videos like that and you start
dissecting this and say i gotta move
5000 applications and
you know if somebody wants to use this
model there's all these complexity
that's going to get added to things and
things i have to solve for and oh by the
way this is a way of thinking that i
maybe never had to have in the past
so i think a lot of people see the
vision
but again implementing it is a total
different ballgame and that's where
it becomes incumbent on having all those
networking constructs to to make it easy
and path of least resistance to move
into the cloud for a large enterprise
and i call this a grow with google model
right so
while we have a lot of people that are
you know hyped on the the service
um the service architecture model it's
kind of like
the grand canyon right i can't expect
somebody to leap across the grand canyon
right i have to get them into the
environment
then i have to build these small
stepping stones right i have to start
introducing things like psc kind of like
i mentioned like using it to maybe front
end google apis
introduce as a small stepping stone so
that they can
take these small steps to get across the
grand canyon and aren't trying to make
this fundamental leap from
here's where i am today to here's where
google you know sees us
in the future but i mean you're right
it's growing with google and i think
we're continuously investing in
providing those stepping stones that
better translate and map to traditional
networking models meanwhile customers
are also
becoming more accustomed to um adopting
and taking on the approach of service
oriented models with
the emergence of their newer
applications that are cloud native yeah
and kind of what i mentioned in the
first video too right there's the
technology aspect of it right how do i
implement the technology but then
there's the how does the organization
operate right
um i can build a lot of things right and
and google
and we build tons of different network
architectures with our customers
but at some point i have to hand it over
to an operations team and the only thing
i can ever guarantee about any network
that i build
is it will break at some point right
this is like the one guarantee i'm
willing to make
so it's not just a matter of like take
the technology and implement technology
but it's also like i was mentioning in
the previous conversation
thinking about how you operationalize
this stuff right like what sort of
operational impacts does it have to your
existing monitoring suite the existing
tools you use the existing processes the
existing mindset
that a network engineer goes through to
troubleshoot a problem
right if you're starting to abstract
more of the network away you've got to
think about like well how do i
troubleshoot problems when the service
doesn't work right if i don't have this
ability to everything and maybe
i'm using some google tools that are new
to me it's going to be a little bit of a
you know
a cultural shift right yeah and you were
just talking about having to overcome
technical debt
and we're trying to provide a path of
least resistance for our customers
but what does that begin to look like uh
what is google cloud doing
in this space to provide an easier path
or a lower barrier to entry
so again i think this goes back to
having the right tools in the toolbox
right and to me tools are features and
capabilities
at a networking layer right so the path
of least resistance
right ideally is i'm gonna take my data
center and i'm gonna forklift it in
in the entire same way that operates
today in google cloud with zero changes
right that would be the ideal i guess
path of least resistance because
literally nothing changes
right the bottom line is that's that's
basically impossible
you can't do it for a number of reasons
okay
so when we're having those conversations
with customers you know we talk about
like what are the stepping stones that a
particular customer
can adopt and that they can get their
head around using
um you know even just the concept of
like our basic level vpc right like
if you're talking about a data center a
data center is a physical building in a
physical location
okay the and your network when you start
talking about like the local area
network or in that data center it's you
know maybe it's in dallas texas as an
example
and then you move into cloud and you're
like well now i have this construct of a
vpc which is kind of like my data center
network but
it can be a global construct okay that's
interesting well how do i set up routing
in there how do i do all this stuff oh
you know we tell people all the time
like you don't have to do a lot because
our andromeda sdn will take care of a
lot of things
right it's different from a lot of our
competitors where you're having to build
a lot of network infrastructure like
vpns or the things to connect you know
region a to region b
that starts to look in some ways like
you know connecting two data centers
i've got to build network between them
then you come to google and it's like
well i can run stuff in europe and i can
run stuff in apac and it can seamlessly
talk together
yeah and you don't have to build any
network sure like we take care of all
that for you again we've kind of
abstracted it under the under the hood
um so like that's just an example of
you know that in itself is a fundamental
difference right like
you could build a vpc that exists only
in one region and kind of make it look
and feel like a data center but
generally speaking i would advise a
customer not to do that right so
that would be one of those sort of
stepping stones let's start thinking
about your network as this global
construct
that exists in a different way than an
individual data center does
so the more sort of tools i have in the
toolbox and again when i say tools i'm
talking about like product features
to say okay you do things this way today
and and
changing that piece of your environment
is too like too difficult for you to do
okay i want to be able to let you move
that over apples to apples
but this other piece of the environment
maybe we can move from apples to oranges
and this other piece i can more
drastically change from like apples to
cherries right
that's what i do every day right i'm
talking to customers and figuring out
like how do we move from here to here
but get some of the advantages of cloud
right even if we're talking about just
network-centric things right we're not
talking about any of the service
oriented models you know let's talk
about what your network looks like two
years out what do you want it to look
like and how do we help you
take it from where it is today to where
you want it to be in
two years three years four years yeah
and i think that eases the concern
when you are looking at it from the
perspective of being a partner
over the span of years as opposed to
we're asking you
to make an entire shift of model and
thinking
in the span of six months but rather how
can we get you to this new
world of service orientation over the
span of two to three years which is more
i think reasonable for people to
accept um and then you're also talking i
think you've also mentioned that you
have a viewpoint that google cloud and
other providers should be providing
more traditional networking tools or at
least the ability to translate what
you've been doing
in your current environment into the
cloud so when you say these things
do you mean offer more customization the
ability to control more of the routing
layers
things like that or is it more just
about tools in the toolbox
uh yeah i mean you know again when i say
tools i'm talking about like product
features and things like that right so
the
you know one i mentioned earlier with
routing is let's say you do a whole
bunch with um
you know bgp filtering policies and
things like that or you're using local
pref in a certain way to
to drive routing that's not something we
offer today with our cloud router it's
something i'm talking to the cloud
router team about and saying like hey
what do we what can we do to sort of
offer
you know more and more of these basic
level features that customers are using
within their data center to manipulate
routing
so those are those are the type of
things that that
i'm talking about with the teams and
when i say like you know offer
these you know these tools to these
products the more of those i have in the
toolbox and i use that term loosely on
toolbox right it allows you
allows us again to create that
apples-to-apple sort of scenario now the
one thing that's different that i do
want to sort of talk about too is
you know when you build a data center
right you're it's typically a very
capital
intensive thing right you're going out
there and you're buying all this
equipment and it's very it's what we
call a heavy capex model right
you can buy all these routers and
switches and they have a whole list of
features
and you put them in the data center and
you use them for 5 years 10 years 15
years whatever
right and you're and then what happens
is once they've
lived their life you have another big
capital spend and you upgrade that
router and you get a whole bunch more
feature functionality out of it
potentially okay
this is kind of the mindset that people
have have done right i built the data
center day one and it's gonna live that
way for the next five years or ten years
i'm gonna make small incremental changes
but i'm not going to make any
fundamental changes because
i spent all this capital over here cloud
flips that model on its head right
you're not buying routers anymore it is
a very opex driven model
right so you're paying for these
services month over month you're not
saying i have this huge bucket of cash
i'm spending here and then
10 years down the road i'm having
another huge bucket of cash so
why is that important well in this opex
model where you're buying more managed
services like i was saying we're
constantly introducing new
features and new tools in the toolbox to
change the architecture and to change
the way that you can do things
so if you have this mentality of i build
it this way and then it's going to live
for five years and i'm gonna change it
you're not getting the full advantage
out of cloud right the whole the whole
point of cloud in some ways is to be
able to make changes
more periodically even if you know again
go back to the customer who yelled at me
and said you know it's very difficult
for us to do
the more you can adopt that mindset the
more you can capitalize
on the evolution that cloud is making
right like we're launching new features
and we're giving you new capabilities
you want to continuously be integrating
them not thinking like you do in a
traditional data center model where
i got this modeled i'm going to change
it in five years it's like i tell
customers every six months
you should be looking at like what do we
need to change in the architecture how
do we roll this architecture forward
but if you're taking those incremental
changes every six months
it's much easier to get to like your
two-year vision your five-year vision
versus maybe that traditional mentality
so again i think people need to think
about cloud differently just from
that standpoint right it's an opex model
you're not spending capex which should
make it easier for you to be integrating
these changes
over the course of time versus making
these very large step
function changes to the way things are
running in the cloud environment
yeah i think you having that background
in traditional networking
helps you understand where a lot of
these customers are coming from
and it is about crawl walk and run but i
do see that some customers are probably
gonna
think okay well i don't really have a
project that would require me to be in
the cloud just yet because everything's
operating on premise but perhaps there
is a team that is the cloud disrupter at
the company
who might have a test project or a test
dev environment that they want to start
operating in the cloud
and so thus i think that relationship
between network
and the developers or other teams would
be important than that case to
actually identify these use cases where
you can start adopting
these models in the cloud um but i do
want to zoom out just a little bit and
talk about
the future of where this is all heading
where do you see cloud networking
heading
i see that we're fine we're getting to a
point where things are converging
with networking and service oriented
models but what do you think is going to
be the future for
cloud and for google cloud in this space
so
it's definitely you know as we've been
kind of orbiting around this
this service networking model right that
is the future hands down
like i i don't see it being anything
other than this okay
um and you know again
just look at how google operates right
we operate services
even though like i talked about earlier
we run a very complex network
at the end of the day we don't run a
network to run the network we run
services the network is just
part of it right and you look at so as
an example you look at how our sre teams
operate right we have sre teams
that operate in kind of these verticals
right so they operate disservice
this service has you know networking as
part of it but there's a lot of other
components right
and that's how our sre teams operate now
we have a networking sre team that kind
of
you know goes horizontally across things
right and that's you're always going to
have some level of expertise there but
i see us as an operating company right
who are operating services
we're building the structure around
these services themselves and then
there's these stuff that's kind of
wrapped around them to support those
services
and that includes networking right and
all of the constructs that exist
in networking right it will continue to
evolve to be more of this
service oriented construct whether we we
like it or not
and like you said i can empathize with
customers because there's some level of
uncomfortability
if that's a word but i get very
uncomfortable just trying to learn all
that stuff and trying to
sort of get my head around it because
it's not my background right i'm like
the traditional router guy like let's
build the routes let's do all this stuff
you know let's not
the whole concept of like service
discovery and service meshes like i get
it at the surface
but when you peel back the onion you
realize just how complex it is and
when you don't have 20 years of
experience doing it it's it's very
daunting right
so i think to answer your direct
question that is the future
20 years from now i think networking
there'll be a lot more managed services
in play that is obfuscating or you know
managing a lot of the networking
and the network engineer 20 years from
now will probably be very different than
like the network engineer
who works in the industry today so if
you're a young network engineer and
you're just getting started
like you want to start digesting all of
that stuff because that's going to be
very commonplace in 10 years hopefully
at that point maybe i'm retired and i
don't have to worry about it
but that is where things are going right
like this is
the whole point of having these
conversations three years ago i wasn't
having these conversations
now more and more of the conversations
are like you know the service oriented
construct and what is google offering
here what is google's vision of the
future and it really is
all of these sort of things is
traditional networking ever going to
completely go away absolutely not
right like it's always going to be there
you need routers still
exist and routes still exist to move
bits and bytes back and forth right
um it's just a matter of like how
they're built and sort of the constructs
that we're using over the top that i
think
change and you start to be less focused
on the network
and start focusing more on the services
themselves
all right well thank you so much again
ryan for covering this
somewhat less talked about topic um you
have an important job in the coming
years
to help customers move to and adopt a
service oriented model in the cloud
at least before you retire and at the
same time you want to be able to
support more of a traditional
network-oriented model whether it's
lift and shift or conversion into the
cloud
so i just want to thank you again for
being on the show and thank everybody
else
for joining and for tuning in yeah and
i'd love for people that are watching
this you know
was this interesting to hear for us to
talk about um what are some other topics
you'd like to see us talk about um
i have things i think are great and
interesting but i'd love to hear from
people that are out there in the world
uh and happy to look at your comments
and and brainstorm around how we can
deliver some more content to you
yeah exactly so if there's anything we
covered today that was of interest or we
didn't get
to a question that you might have about
this topic please comment below
we are actually going to read all of
them and respond to all of your comments
thank you so much everyone for joining
and check out our next episodes coming
out
thanks for tuning in thanks
you